we have a voicemail number and that
number is 219 to david p
here's a caller who always leaves very
trollish questions but there's actually
some
meaty sort of substance here to talk
about let's play it and then we'll
discuss
a real question with real substance
please
should big pharma
pay for the education of doctors
since all of their doctors basically
push their pharmaceuticals right
i don't see them pushing
vitamins minerals nutrition
[Music]
good food healthy food unprocessed foods
ultra processed foods
all that stuff is bad for you
but they push pharmaceuticals
please answer that question okay so the
caller is sort of confused now what i i
am i have to assume that what the caller
means by should pharmaceutical companies
be allowed to educate doctors i assume
what they mean is that pharmaceutical
companies send their own reps to tell
doctors about medications and how they
work and it is sales it is essentially
saying to doctors here's a great
medication for conditions prescribe this
i assume that that's what the caller is
talking about and that entire
infrastructure is very problematic in
the united states we also have in the
u.s i believe it's the u.s and
new zealand
i think
the only two countries where you can
directly market medications to consumers
through media like you you see ads on tv
ask your doctor about this medication or
that medication that's a major problem
now that being said
um i think
there are more and more doctors who are
talking generally speaking about the
importance of a good and healthy diet
understanding uh just basics about
nutrition
undoing bad or flawed ideas i you know i
know
many doctors in many specialties who
talk to me about they try to have
conversations with patients that are
much more general about lifestyle
and so i i don't think it's fair to say
that doctors aren't doing that i do
think that unfortunately particularly
when you look at specialists
specialists tend to be dealing with
um
disease in a way where
you have to use the tools available at
the time and so if someone comes in and
they have you know skin cancer or they
already have diabetes
of course you talk about
lifestyle and you should generally wear
sunscreen when you go out in the sun and
you should eat a healthy diet in order
to improve the the diabetes but you also
have to deal with the situation as it is
and sometimes that includes medication
or surgical interventions or whatever
the case may be but i i don't i don't
find this question to be this guy calls
in and always says i'm a troll and i'm
asking trolling questions i think
there's some confusion in the caller
but i think that there is no question
that doctors are understanding uh these
kind of structural and systemic factors
and the importance of of a healthy
lifestyle and all of that at the at the
tail end of it there's this very kind of
pernicious thing where
you know
there are conditions
that
are very much lifestyle related and if
everybody did quote what they were
supposed to do
you would almost put some specialists
out of business because all of a sudden
you reduce the number of people with
that condition i get that i get that i
get that a lot of money is made treating
conditions that are
um preventable in many cases and that's
a conversation we've also had but it's a
little bit different than what the
caller is asking we have a great bonus
show for you today more and more
democrats are getting anxious about joe
biden just getting the replacement on
the court for stephen breyer sooner than
later
um and we're going to talk about that
there is a jewish student who was
reprimanded
for exposing
that students did a nazi salute in class
it wasn't the students doing the salute
who were reprimanded it was the jewish
student who blew the whistle what
we'll talk about that on today's bonus
show and also we're going to talk about
the organic cotton movement
and we will talk about what is what does
organic cotton mean
and we're going to talk about scams
within that movement as well very
disturbing marketing thing that is going
on all of those stories and more on
today's bonus show don't miss it get
instant access by signing up at
joinpackman.com